I wish it were otherwise but Ser Gregor
is beyond saving
well we're beyond this man not even a
maester let alone grand maester that's
for the best
my son knows how to save him that is
exactly the sort of arrogance that had
him expelled from the Citadel your grace
his curiosity was deemed dangerous and
unnatural
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I want to
do somewhat of a character breakdown
video on Qyburn but what I really want
to talk about is what his plans are for
the future
Qyburn has been working for Cersei for
many years now but he is still a very
mysterious character who may have a
hidden agenda of his own
Qyburn is a former maester of the
Citadel but he was stripped of his chain
and thrown out after he was caught doing
some very unethical experiments it is
common for maesters to perform autopsies
on dead bodies but Qyburn took this a
step further he started to do
experiments on people that were still
alive and this is a no-no in the eyes of
the Citadel Qyburn may be a disgrace
according to other masters but his
unorthodox two methods have made him one
of the most knowledgeable healers in all
of Westeros after he was kicked out of
the Citadel we really don't know what
Qyburn was up to after this in season 3
he somehow ends up as one of the
prisoners at Harrenhal he was badly
wounded but he does survive and he stays
at Harrenhal where he begins to serve
Roose Bolton and this is how he meets
Jaime Lannister and ultimately ends up
healing Jaime's infected stump and he
also helps escort Jaime back to King's
Landing in season 4 Qyburn enter Cersei
service and he has been extremely loyal
to her ever since
any task she sets upon him he has been
able to see to its completion and as of
right now it doesn't seem like this is
going to change but we still don't know
if Qyburn has his own ulterior motives
you have to wonder if he is serving
Cersei so that he can put himself in
position to complete his own secret
plans it's really hard to say what his
true intentions are because Qyburn has
always kind of just hanging out in the
background
and he doesn't associate with too many
other people for us to see if he has any
plans of his own one thing everyone can
say about him is he is extremely
effective at his work he basically
brought the mountain back from the dead
not only did he save him but you can say
the mountain is stronger and more loyal
now than he has ever been the mountain
has vowed to never speak until he kills
all of Circe's enemies can you imagine
if Qyburn was able to do this with every
soldier in the Lannister army that would
make one hell of a force
I think Cersei should consider herself
lucky to have Qyburn in her service he
is largely responsible for keeping
Cersei in power which she has rewarded
him handsomely by making this disgraced
former maester the hand of the Queen to
the Seven Kingdoms
Qyburn was the one who ensured that the
septa bail or would be sitting on a
ticking time bomb of wildfire he was
also the one who had the Scorpions made
to take down Danny's dragons and I think
both of these weapons will come into
play once again in the final season and
it will be Qyburn to be the one to make
sure of this he didn't have a huge role
in season seven but the things he did
were very useful for Cersei but there
was one thing that Qyburn did do that
intrigued me and this was in the dragon
pit during the white presentation Qyburn
expressed great interest in these
inhuman creatures
[Music]
[Music]
we can destroy them by burning them
Qyburn did not appear to be startled but
instead he was very interested in how
the whites worked he picked up the
whites hand and he began to study it for
a few moments until John took the hand
and demonstrated that it could be killed
with fire and you have to imagine Qyburn
was taking note of everything that was
happening this is Chi burns
bread-and-butter his life's work is
understanding the human anatomy and I am
curious to know if Qyburn has his own
plans for the army of the Dead the
mountain is a perfect example that
proves Qyburn studies necromancy and he
may be wondering if he can figure out a
way to raise an entire force of his own
on the other hand khyber may be thinking
of a way he can stop the army of the
dead
he heard John say that fire can stop
them and I have always believed ever
since season six ended that Qyburn has
been busy making more wildfire behind
the scenes
suggest a minnow something magical we
might not see Qyburn that often but he
is always doing things without us
knowing he was looking into the wildfire
before the set was blown up and he
already had a scorpion made before we
even knew he was looking into it when
Qyburn saw the destruction of the Sept
of Baelor you have to think he wanted to
have more wildfire made or at the very
least find all of the other hidden
caches a wild fire underneath King's
Landing Cersei was definitely scared of
that white when it came charging after
her and I wouldn't be surprised if she
went to Qyburn and made sure more
wildfire was available just in case the
army of the Dead make it that far south
plus Cersei would probably blow up the
city before she ever stepped down from
the throne and bent the knee to Daenerys
or John now that Cersei and Khyber know
the whites can be killed with fire I
would expect to see more wildfire next
season but I think the most interesting
thing of all is KY Byrnes fascination
with the human anatomy in his
experiments with the dark arts
Qyburn in the night King both practiced
necromancy in a sense and I am wondering
if there will be any connection in terms
of the endgame or how the army of the
Dead are ultimately defeated KY Burns
knowledge with how the human body works
could become even more useful now than
ever before we have seen the night King
bring several different species back to
life and he is obviously using some kind
of ancient magic to be able to do this
but you have to wonder if Qyburn will
figure out a way to tap into this magic
on the same scale as well we have seen
him sort of do this with the mountain
but if he was able to channel the exact
same magic the knight King uses he may
be able to figure out a way to
counteract it or create an army of his
own this is assuming Qyburn would be
willing to use his skills for the
betterment of Westeros but considering
who Qyburn works for he may end up using
this knowledge for something much darker
if Qyburn was able to discover how to
raise an entire army that would act
under his commands
you just know Cersei would use this
against Daenerys and John Qyburn has
been dabbling in these dark arts for
quite some time now and if there was
going to come a time to where he was
going to master this
practice it would be in the final season
when everything is put onto the table
during an interview the actor who plays
kiya Barton was asked about the scene
when he was holding the whites hand and
when he was asked what his character was
thinking this is what he said that's
where his head is you know the world
could end in five minutes but he is
absolutely focused on I have never seen
this before this is amazing I could
really do things with this I thought
that was a very interesting thing to say
now we know the actors and actresses
aren't allowed to reveal anything but I
would like to think this could become a
plot point next season what are KY Burns
plans for the army of the Dead
now that he has witnessed at firsthand
what is going through his mind
I am hoping we get another sneak peek of
Qyburn working in his lab because I
would like to see what kind of crazy
creation he comes up with next
I think they shown us Qyburn picking up
that hand for a reason and I doubt that
was just a throwaway scene not with what
Qyburn already knows I believe this mad
scientist will get back to work and
possibly figure out exactly how to tap
into this magic that raises the dead I
just hope he uses any newfound knowledge
to help defeat them instead of raising
an army for Cersei I told everyone on my
patreon that I was gonna be making this
video next that way I could feature some
of your thoughts in the video and this
is what some of you had to say
Casey Lee says Qyburn intrigues me we
first see him with the dead in Harrenhal
but nothing is known of him before why
would a failed maester be with an army
marching on the mountain who was thought
to be there still who was he before
Richard says I think that Qyburn can
come up with a way other than fire
dragonglass in Valyrian steel to kill
them after what he did to the mountain
in the Scorpions there's nothing that he
could do that would surprise me he makes
Cersei more dangerous shadow says I
think he was trying to figure out the
night Kings method her spells I would
like any info on his backstory he maybe
figure out how to kill the night king or
maybe even prevent people from being
raised as whites by use of dragonglass
or another color or magic and potions or
he can raise the dead himself
Frankenstein style to fight against the
whites that's a bit of tin foil but oh
well it's a long night I don't think
that's ten foil at all I think high barn
is
definitely capable of doing something
like this I completely agree with what
all of you had to say and I am
interested in learning more about this
mysterious mad scientist known as Qyburn
hand of the Queen let me know what you
think down below what are your thoughts
on Qyburn do you think he has any plans
for the army of the Dead I would like to
see what everyone has to say about this
topic thanks for stopping by to check
out the video I really appreciate that
and thank you to all of my patreon
supporters have a great day everyone
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]